my guest tonight of course is very
talented actor uh could i we'll get to
you in just a second please
please no no don't read ahead
he's a very talented actor keep going
who's starred in the popular tv
sitting down justified and deadwood will
this work we have
no this is awful he was also in the co i
said quantum
he's also in the quentin tarantino film
once upon a time in hollywood
please welcome what says here our good
friend we'll fix that later
timothy oliphant timothy where are you
yes good to see you buddy
[ __ ] i blew it i came out with the mug
and i got it it's fine it was supposed
to be here do you want to do it again no
no that supposed to come out and it's
there
trust me i kind of gave away it's fine
it's beautiful
please although because he got up we do
have to take his temperature
is that it yeah
[Laughter]
wait what's that is that andy yeah i'm
right here which one is it tim i'm over
here over that way
i'm over here i'm the one that's vaguely
movable
sometimes it was hard to tell at first i
don't know if it's because the cardboard
cutouts are so
lifelike or um
yeah yeah we get it
look the point is you have brought a lot
of energy oh sorry
yeah may i go ahead because i i
shouldn't do a lot of talking here on
conan i am
conan conan
what is your last name it's o'brien
o'brien
uh my brother called today by the way i
told him i was coming to see you he said
tell him he's still my favorite o'brien
that's a lousy anyway no hold on a
second because a lot of times and
you were alluding to this i'll come on
your show if we can still call it that
um what the hell's going on
just hey take it easy uh and you know we
do the we do bits
yeah and i run around and we we i have a
lot of
pre-planned anecdotes and and uh yes uh
one might argue that i interrupt you a
lot and but i want you to know today
i'm just here to listen that's really
great
because you don't do a lot of quick
questions yes
[Laughter]
when's the audience coming back they're
not coming back
here's what i think is going to happen
our plan is as you know we're wrapping
up the day in day out show
that the final one is on the on june
24th so the last three weeks
we're going to be you know we're going
to sort of really ramp it up do a lot of
fond look back and then the last
two weeks audiences real audiences
so in like two weeks no no no no no no
no don't
we want you here now can't wait to see
him no no i can't wait to see him
no no tim tim tim come back
and once you hear we've tested you why
do i have to be here now
because we've tested you you do very
well with cardboard
you are you're an electrifying presence
you don't need an audience you and i
have a
thing people talk about it it's a thing
we have
is that and we're uh we're okay with
that yes okay yeah
sort of an what's the word antipathy is
that it
yes sort of you know we bump up against
each other
you know there's a anger and a jealousy
but there's also a love and affection
too i haven't seen you in it's been a
while
yeah i mean we we saw each other once
like early in this whole
pandemic yeah i came to your house do
you remember this
i came to your house and sat in your
front yard oh that's right with your
wife and kids and we all sat around
wearing masks and i
chatted you guys up and then your kids
gave you like a signal which
clearly meant he's got to go i saw them
do that they're very cool beautiful kids
uh but they made it clear that i should
move along and it was sad and then i
just walked
away from your house like a sad hobo i
miss seeing you i miss hanging out with
you
going to dinner it's opening up now we
can we can all we could
get the y's we could go out to dinner
what's not right hang on let's not rush
it let's
wait another year in person uh
you're very interesting you know what i
mean
i don't feel like the audience doesn't
you don't uh the audience doesn't see
that side of you
it's very fascinating when we get
together in real life
he basically just said you've been
boring for 30 years
so you're saying you know me personally
and you think in person
in person but on tv what happens
well that's the question isn't it
right but you know what you got you how
many weeks you got left
we got a couple of weeks left it's not
too late
let them in let them in you know what
i'm gonna here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna be you know what i mean what
are you what are you holding your gaze
on the audience for
just you know the money's over here it's
right here this is the prize right here
i see you new young yeah you've been
doing so much great stuff i understand
you went back to school during
quarantine
i did i went back to college yeah how'd
you do that did you do it online
i did i realized i wasn't gonna be
working for a while even though
uh uh yeah i realized uh like many
people out there i wasn't gonna be
working for a while but
um i was fortunate enough to be able to
uh
i really i i hadn't for
i don't i didn't have my degree i never
got my degree oh you never got your
degree yeah no i was like two
uh 2.7 units shy
of a degree and i just it was just kind
of sitting there for years and years and
years
and i realized this is usc i went to usc
yeah yeah and so i realized um
my wife and i were taking classes anyway
just kind of online classes they were
really kind of fun and i realized wait i
should take a class and get my degree
i'm we're here i got the time it was
amazing
so i called up uh i reached out to
some advisor you know academic people
over at the campus
and they pulled up my file from whatever
and
i re-enrolled and got my student id and
and um reached out to the fine art
department because i
i could take i was anything i could do
elective but i was like i really want to
go back and
work with the fine art department again
and then it turns out
my college professor one of my college
professors who i worked
was so fond of and worked so closely
with the wonderful
ruth weisberg who became the dean of the
fine art department i'm going to get
into more detail it's going to be
fascinating for you
and i think for the listeners did you
take a course online in finishing an
anecdote
by any chance
those take time forget it listen um
i think it's great that you went back
first we're back you're a talented
artist i don't think people know that
about you you're a very talented artist
and you went back and you got your
degree
i got my degree and i i was my thing i
got to work with the same
not only did i go back 30 whatever years
later i worked with the same professor
who i worked with when i was in college
and it was a it was just an
amazing experience i want to show people
a picture of you
yeah yeah we have it this is you at usc
there you go and um absolutely
incredible andy any thoughts
i think we showed this once before and i
said that is a really cute lesbian
i just wanted to hear it again that was
me
you're adorable they put my that's
i was i was on the uh i was gonna make a
crew team joke
remember the usc thing the girl put her
head on a thing and then yeah he put her
on the crew team
yeah yeah there was a during the college
cheating scandal cheating scandal
they they put uh you know some of the
moms that were indicted uh were
were caught putting uh the girl's head
on the body of someone who was really
rowing
on the crew team even though their kid
didn't row crew right and then she got
kicked out of school for that yeah which
i think was the wrong course of action
you thought that was the wrong
punishment what's the right punishment
they should have forced her to
do crew
[Laughter]
i mean because crew is what you got to
get up there at like five in the morning
yeah can you imagine she when that one
went down and she was like i guess i'm
out of here they should have said no no
no sit down yeah yeah practice tomorrow
morning
we'll see you there put her on a little
little canoe whatever what you know it's
not a canoe stroke
have you ever done trouble have you ever
done crew no i'm okay cause you just
called it a canoe
oh you look like you did crew though
thanks a lot pal you don't get these
broad shoulders just hanging around
what sports did you play
let me say it again what sports did you
try to play
well that's terrible that's mean try to
play what was sports i was a fine hacky
sack player
uh i ran track uh for a while in high
school um
was not very good and didn't do well at
it i had very small lungs
at the time that's what the problem was
i think it was very small lungs
the lungs disproportionately small lungs
uh but i i ran did you have those giant
feet like where you just couldn't like
it was just tough
you know did you you didn't i wasn't
like a baby bronte no no
yeah you did though right yes my son who
you know
he was a tall lanky kid yeah remember
that yeah and uh
and uh and um i remember once talking to
him and i think we were talking about
uh skiing yeah and i was like come on
let's we're all gonna go skiing we'll go
snowboarding he's like come on dad i
want to ski
why not you look oh come on man i got a
hard enough time walking
i feel like that's really i had very
large feet yeah uh
still do and did you ever trip in a
competition
and just fall like on nothing did that
ever happen
yes were you just literally out of the
blocks and you fell yeah
i felt before we went before they fired
the gun and i fell
after they fired the gun i know uh no i
shouldn't have been out there
i shouldn't have been out there you of
course a terrific athlete we have photos
and video footage of it now no we don't
no there's no footage of it i had it
destroyed
um so this is your fun thing to do
you're obviously a
very talented man a very good looking
man a very good athlete and you love to
come on here and point out that i'm not
those things that's your fun little no i
just was wondering what sports you did
sure sure you did you said track yeah
okay high school i didn't play a sport
in college
let's just say comedy was my sport
and i know you well and i know you're a
legend uh not just now like people know
you're a comedy legend but you were like
a comedy legend
in college this is i love this part of
the year you were the youngest
person to ever uh be the editor of that
the thing at the at the school what a
lovely tribute
what a lovely well thought out you know
how to be great
you don't have a magazine you know be
great if you hosted a new
a reimagined version of this is your
life you didn't do it
on this channel he didn't do any
research at all yeah so it was like
conan o'brien you did a thing
with the thing and then you met somebody
and then there was another thing
it's gonna be huge that was your life
june 25th tbs
24th no that's when your show ends
my show starts the next day oh um
that's why i'm here was that not clear
i'm here to promote my show
we'll get to that it's called the guest
we're going we're flipping it listen
they said you want to host
i said no i i like being the guest and
they said we could do that and i'm like
oh that's cool so
it's going to be uh so it's the guest
with every week timothy olyphant
you're the guest every week every every
night so every night it's nightly
what do you do now two nights three
nights a week how many nights did a week
do you do we do four
all right but clearly big fan hey so i
do
so the guest four nights a week tbs
i'm going to say one full sentence if it
kills me you played a marshall you could
come on and be a host one night
i can't why why don't you bother
tonight's host
conan o'brien and then you come on
that's funny right
you get it it's a flip incredible i
don't know where you get these ideas
um it's impressive you always have good
ideas
your kids must have been impressed that
you were in
once upon a time in hollywood they love
that because
it was the coolest movie it's tarantino
and then it's all these huge stars
did you did you like you took them to
the premiere right i took um
i took the oldest two i can't remember
why the youngest one didn't come
they'd never been to a premiere it was
very exciting
um uh they really enjoyed it
you know it was amazing i mean they it's
really nice now they're older and that
you can kind of do these things and you
know
um i think they're all they're enjoying
it
and and uh and it's not so
relatively not so crazy and bizarre and
overwhelming but and
they love tarantino movies and they were
thrilled just that and they
met leonardo dicaprio and brad pitt and
they were that
all of that was very exciting they
flipped
over snoop dogg though snoop dogg was
there snoop dogg was at the premiere
it was really quite something it's
amazing the power of music and
specifically him i guess because
you know they had met all these
incredible people they were very excited
or that seemed cool and they were having
and then snoop walked in and it was like
they just went right it's a whole other
level of excitement
oh my god they went yeah they were like
oh my god
and we're like well there's like snoops
here and you know i was like should we
we i had a friend in common and they're
like
yes they want to go meet snoop so my
wife i took was my wife our oldest
daughter
and and my son uh we we we walked over
and uh my friend introduced me to
snoop and um god bless him
he looked at me and i and just said uh
you're a bad mother
yes i know right because i tried to play
it real quick it's the ultimate
compliment
i tried to play it real cool and i was
like wow thanks and he goes no
you're a bad he said twice and inside
because my kids are right there
inside there's a little me going yes
yes right like yeah see told you
yeah right he says that a lot though it
doesn't matter
he met my mom like eight years ago and
that's what he said to her
bad mother my mom high-fived him
and they smoked some chronic out in an
alley it was a good time
but uh but i'm glad he said it to you
too you know what you know what it's
rude you're just upstaging my anecdote
nope not enough isn't even that good of
an anecdote that was a good anecdote but
you know what i did i put a little
cherry on the
level you know what i'm gonna start over
nope
no time for that listen there's no
transition we can't
afford those now you get mistaken a lot
for actor
josh duhamel okay in fact
today i was pretty sure we booked josh
dumel we were excited
and then that's why i'm here again i'm
here to promote
something uh something on netflix
that's why i'm here isn't it stunning
stunning how much he looks like josh
dumoul
yeah here's a side by side picture of
the two of them
i don't even know i can't tell which one
is you you know he did
i think though dumel is like the large
version and he's the medium version
because dumel is a big tall man
yeah now this is this is true i i can
vouch
i tell you you know he did my um
he god bless him he he did the uh my
family christmas card
he posed he posed with my family for
and uh we sent it out as my yeah is that
true that's absolutely wait so you got
josh dumel to pose with your wife and
kids
and you're not in the picture yeah no i
have it on my phone i'm gonna show it to
you
i we so
for years i've been hearing this goes
way back early 2000 like i've been
hearing you know this guy josh duamel
was like no he said you guys look a lot
alike you know and we had friends in
common
and then i'd get mistaken for him and uh
my wife just would love that she'd just
needle me you know like oh
it's just do a mill you know and i'd be
like often
um she loved it though
yeah and then i i just we had friends
and comments so i knew he often
we had this mutual thing we get mistaken
for one another
so we're at this uh we're out at dodger
stadium
and um and for a charity event that
clayton kershaw was putting on
my buddy aj ellis at the time was
playing for the dodgers there's a lot of
names involved
let me you want me to tell you about my
all the people the college professor
i'll pay you not to thank you so anyway
help me out stay on track i'm right here
i'm right here with you
you're playing this charity event we're
dodgers and there he is
josh duamel yes and we've never met and
as soon as we see each other
just laughter just laughter just years
of his
what we both and anyway uh long story
short if that's still possible
i say hey dude my family whole family's
here
would you take a picture with them and
uh he
uh very kindly obliged and it was
wonderful
but we sent this out as happy holidays
from all the elephants and josh
here's the picture here where am i
putting it look at that so
all i know is that uh right around uh
the holidays my brother calls me
uh from my mom's place he says i'm here
at mom's
and your christmas card's on the
refrigerator uh with all the holiday
cards and
mom saying don't doesn't don't they lo
everyone look great
and my my brother says mom you know
that's not tim right
she's like what are you talking about
she goes that's not
tim in the card your mom didn't show
that's an
actor named josh duhamel
and i swear to you according to my
brother he said
mom lit peeks in and goes i thought he
looked taller
i sent that we we now extend exchange
holiday cards he's on the holiday card
mailing list he got a card that year
from us and i got a card from him and
the only difference was is
he was in both cards yeah yeah so
you know what he can do no wrong as far
as i'm concerned everyone should watch
his show
on netflix yeah it's like a superhero
thing i think it's great yeah
[Laughter]
and he'll be watching your show the
guest starring timothy guess he could
come on and be a host
yeah you're not taking that mug with you
we're hanging on to those those are
collectors items um
tim you're a wonderful fellow it is
go ahead i was just gonna wrap it up
someone needs to i mean it's
it seemed like um it's a lot of pressure
this is our last
interview on this particular show so
what they've been so many versions of
shows right that whatever you know you
shouldn't feel any pressure
but this is the last like i read the i
read
and we haven't even talked about this um
what did the doctors say what do you
have and how long have they been
let's get that rumor started uh they
said it's just too much talent
and yeah actually it is
destroying my immune system i have so
much talent right and uh they said
you've got to just stop for a while
i know it hurts for me to be so close to
it trust me
you know i mean like i can feel it yeah
yeah you know when i first read
you and you know this because i called
you because i read
the when i read that this version of
this show was ending
right um i have to say because my you
know
we've been friends for a long time and
so when i read it my
my i i thought immediately as soon as i
saw it i thought
what does this mean for me um
you know and then but then right
i thought oh and andy and then
and then i thought i should call conan
yeah um several weeks later i heard from
you because
no yeah but whatever you will always be
in some version doing something with
each other romantic
i feel like before i go i should say
something of value about how much this
show and and uh this
friendship and we met on this show it's
true
yeah no you you came on the show and
you came on the show and we became
friendly and i knew right away this is a
guy
who will be a friend of mine and
interrupt me in my
personal life and my professional life
never let me finish a sentence
this is a guy who can do that for me the
rest of my life i think i said something
you know that bit we did we should get
together and actually we talked about
this
bit idea and i remember saying we should
get together and and um
and actually do that and you said you
know or we could just get together and
go have a dinner
drinks or something and not do the bit
and not do the bit
which crushed my show business dreams
but
um because i think the bit could have
been big but uh
but i really appreciate it and then uh
it was just sort of like yeah give me
your number give me a we exchanged uh we
text
exchange numbers boom boom boom done you
know a lot of times in show business
somebody says hey we should have dinner
then the next thing i know is i have
someone's assistant reach out to my
agent who reaches
out to me and then i never see that
person well i can't do that i'm not
interested my assistant doesn't do
anything i ask her to do
okay to be fair you would have screwed
that up if i had said can you call tim
olyphant you'd have screwed it up
that's not true it is true you'd have
called him and set up a dinner with you
and tim
oh yeah in fact
[Laughter]
yeah no he's really cool yeah yeah
listen whatever that
that you know listen i know you've
you've told me about the problems yes
with sona
what they're legendary
he said you're aware of them and then it
doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter anymore i don't
know what he's talking about
okay but but you'll you know this over
the years
i don't know how many years it's been we
don't we don't we don't ever
like i never get like oh conan wants to
have dinner at this restaurant
from he just handles it all on his on
his own
yeah that's me i see that as a sign of
this is by the way we can stop the
cameras oh they run out of tape
tim they ran out of tape about 40
minutes ago frank how are we doing
by the way do we i tried i had it we
have it we feel like we
have something do we we do we want to no
we've got it
hear more about your teacher that you
haven't seen
i'm ending this we have it in spades
ruth weisberg
first of all is wonderful woman
wonderful work uh we have to turn the
theater back over
and still to the people that own it um
we uh there's there's a high school
graduation coming in
yeah we have to get out of here but
listen you have been a terrific
you're a terrific guest you are a very
good friend
and whatever i do next you'll be a part
of it i promise you even if you don't
want to be
oh that's fantastic but yeah yeah it'll
be great so is there money involved
no be very no money involved just
friendship and loyalty and
not even friendship hey what thank you
so much for coming you know what
timothy oliphant there's no one else
like you and we thank the good lord
every day
you guys are the best you're the best